[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are hearing from link
and his three-year update on where he
stands spiritually
it's all about me to do it baby
man you know what
I'm happy to be doing this in previous
years I didn't I didn't think I was
happy to be doing this at the time but
I'll tell you you would tell me as much
yeah I'm I'm kind of on top of the world
right now oh on top of my little world
my own little link uh
molehill okay you know
I'm just uh
feeling good uh very happy and
um I'm ready to share some stuff that
I've written in my journal oh wow and
written in my journal what do you think
about handwriting you can pick it out
from you can pick it out from a mile
away couldn't you uh yeah I could
definitely pick out your handwriting
it's amazing how it hasn't changed
you know one since like you know back
when we used to write like in high
school
mine changed in college and and so
little I can still pick it out man no no
I'm saying that signature I wrote in
cursive in high school
and I cannot write in cursive if you ask
me to I have some sort of a hybrid here
I don't know if I get real excited it
gets real jumbly and I got really
excited in some of the stuff that uh I
want to share with you today
uh I'm excited to hear yeah this is this
this is good first of all yesterday uh
hit a milestone that just kind of
things were just going great and then 15
000 steps something just put it over the
top
I
got back on my bike oh for the first
time since my injury man I don't know
how we feel about that yeah Christy was
like I was leaving I was like I'm going
to get on my bike and she was like she
gave me this look she was like you come
back with the same number of pieces
that you left him was there any
difference in uh protective gear any
difference in route any difference in
approach yep
um
are you in a bubble now less protective
gear are you you're no longer on a bite
you're just in one of those bubbles
rolling down the mountain uh not as much
protective gear I just wore a helmet I
didn't wear any of my pads because I'm
like I gotta ease back into it this is
okay all right
yes counter-intuitive isn't it well
because maybe the pads give you a false
sense of security no I just
um I'm not in my fitness level is not to
the point where I'm gonna do stuff that
um I'm gonna fall
I'm pretty sure so you know I did some
it was more on the flat side of things
there was a little bit of you know I
went around the dam
and there's a couple of places where
there's some single track because I was
trying to figure out if my
like the shock to the shoulders like the
bumpiness like you know I got the I got
the suspension in the front but a lot of
that's still in your arms and do you
feel anything in that shoulder yeah it's
still it's still tight and not
comfortable exactly but
um
I think the bone is pretty much
healed I last time I went to the doctor
he was like you know give it four more
weeks and you should have complete
reunion of the bone
and so I'll have you come back and we'll
do another X-ray and I was like
do we really need to do that
and he was like I'm fine with you not
coming back if you don't want to come
back and how many weeks ago was that uh
four weeks ago
so now I should as of like
a few two a couple of days ago
it should be totally fixed and there's
no reason to think that it that it
wouldn't be there will come a time in
which I just didn't want to go there get
an x-ray you don't think about it
anymore spend a couple of hours yeah and
I've been going to physical therapy I've
been you know but it's going to be
hanging out of your mind at some point
you know what I'm saying oh yeah Jane is
giving me lots of confidence she's my PT
Guru
um
she's helping me invite things to the
party remember inviting my ribs to the
party that's her oh the same woman yeah
oh yeah she's great is she inviting your
shoulder to the party yeah yeah she she
said she was very proud of me and that
made me feel good but just getting back
out there and then having something that
like okay now
the thing that I'm working towards is
getting back in that spot where I'm like
climbing the mountain where I you know
took the tumble and broke myself
I want to be able to get back there and
it's it's there's a certain Fitness
level to be able to get up the mountain
and then enjoy the breeze in my hand not
my hair because I have a helmet I mean
my face you know exactly coming back
down that mountain
I think I will yeah across there I
didn't die dude yeah I might I might get
off and pour one out you know
pour one out for the for the old bump in
my right shoulder that's now a little
less of a bump but it I mean yeah so
yesterday was really a milestone moment
for me
to be on my bike
and as you'll see in a lot of what I'm
talking about today just trying to
acknowledge
the the moments the special moments in
my life you know
if this is all there is
uh boy I'm grateful for it because I I
really am
#blessed hmm I'm really I you know I'm
really grateful
we got we got a lot of good stuff to be
grateful for agreed you know
um
so I just want to I want to savor those
moments and yesterday being back on the
bike there was a little bit of
nervousness but it was definitely
you know that was um like 11 or 12 weeks
to not do something that's that special
to me was like I really missed it
so it like
I just kind of I wallered like a pig in
that in that mud you know just like um
man this feels good this feels good
right now right now
and right now and right now well right
now really in the moments and right now
in multiple moments
um
so yeah I just wanna
I just want to share my mindset on stuff
and
um
I feel like this is I feel like this is
going to be a happy time I hope you
catch some of it as you're listening I
hope you uh
I hope it makes you happier
you know if you care about me
um
then this is also for you you know I'm
sure I'm sharing I'm sharing my
happiness with you today in this podcast
earbiscus is brought to you by
betterhelp you know we are big fans of
therapy we both benefit from therapy and
we both have you been through a number
of therapists I've been through uh I'm
on my second therapist but I'm still on
my first hey you know what that's that's
unusual my friend but finding therapy is
very important but it's not easy it is
not easy
um and I think that it is an unusual
experience that I just happen to find
somebody who was the right fit for me
um yeah for the first time it happens in
relationships it happens sometimes in
professional relationships with your
therapist but it doesn't always happen
and that's why we're big fans of Better
Health yeah if you're thinking about
giving therapy a try better help's a
great option it's super easy to use it
won't break your bank and you can do
therapy from anywhere because it's
entirely online so you just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and you can switch
the therapist anytime for no additional
charge if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can help get you
there visit betterhelp.com ear today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
when we first started talking about our
our spiritual Journeys it was very much
like that buzzword of like
deconstruction
and like like breaking breaking things
down from
my
um Evangelical upbringing that I've
discovered that I would be better off
shedding
I mean very specifically just like guilt
and shame like this perceived
um constant judgment whether it comes
from God or from
you know people that I respect
um
oh and I think most
constantly myself
my inner critic if you want to call it
um
and as I've as I mentioned at the end of
last year like therapy's been really
good for me over the past year like it's
just really started to click into place
um with with my therapist and
things are going really great there and
one of the exercises that we've worked
on is
just
um discussing it unpacking it but also
kind of getting in my body with it and
breathing
have a breathing exercise where
I breathe in self-compassion and I
breathe out
self-judgment
discovering that it it kept coming up so
much
that I was
so hard on myself so
um it was so ingrained that
yeah my default position is is bad I'm a
bad I'm I'm bad at my core hmm
um
and it just permeated
so much of
how I
live my life how I felt
and how I held myself
um so it was a great like non- again
when you when it's when it's associated
with your breath I I think I'm coming to
learn that like it kind of it's less
about like
um rational brain conclusion stuff and
more about
I don't know you call it heart body kind
of
um
things releasing that didn't reside
fully just in what I would call my my
brain in my head
so breathing
in
compassion breathing out
judgment and
it's it's just been a very good exercise
like literally something that we would
go back to
many weeks in a row to maybe skip a
couple of them didn't find myself coming
back to that exercise
[Music]
so that's just something that
I'm doing more of
it's it it really helps it's been really
helping me and
I think that I'm just done I'm with with
the deconstruction term I don't think
I'm done unpacking
the things that I need to those the
things that are like lurking in some
suitcases that I need to let go of
by the way and I always like to say this
like I just don't I don't want to
just give this impression that like I'm
trashing my entire upbringing and my
former belief system and you're just
throwing it all out
um I cherish so much about that and I've
said that before and so I'm just saying
it again right now like I'm there's
there's parts of what
of how that's built me that uh our
beautiful meaningful and uh I never want
to let go of but the way that me
specifically I the like that the way
that I'm made up everything about me
and my how I interacted with my
environment and
you know it's it there was this equation
of that it was just kind of like
beating myself down for a long time
um and I'm you know it's just this
Alchemy of isn't I'm not going to put it
all on
the church I'm not going to put it all
on myself it's this Alchemy of all of
those things that like in some of that
I'm continuing to un find and unpack
uh so I'm not done with that process but
I'm but I'm done with like I think I'm
at a point where it's like
it's not the main thing that I'm
focusing on anymore it's not the main
thing that I need to focus on like the
the huge things that
I've taken out of the suitcase in terms
of Shame and guilt and self-judgment
you know I've taken them out I'm looking
at them and I think I know that it's
like
at the correct Pace at the natural pace
that it should happen is
dissolving it's dissipating
so I'm left with
um
more of a where do I
where do I where do I go what am I
putting in that suitcase of me
I guess to follow that analogy right
um so
I'm done with it I'm done with saying
I'm deconstructing
I can't remember what I said last year I
might have said the same thing last year
it doesn't matter I think that it's you
know it's
I'm
I'm closer to
uh
I don't know there's just a different
I'm going to say energy there's like
there's a different vibe to just um you
dealing with things that are inside of
you and like
cleaning it up or uh working through it
then
um
becoming more
receiving things we can be more open and
moving forward
you know so Construction Construction a
little bit of construction or should I
say Construction Construction
um
okay so let's talk about this
construction I think my spiritual
practice right now is I is resolving to
know nothing
like for me
I just
that's just not
when it's not interested in that just
not interested in it now when you talk
to me about your journey I'm interested
uh I'm interested in that conversation
like last week everything that you
talked about I was very interested in it
for you it's not like I don't want to
hear about that but like when it comes
to like
my special
inner inner process for me
uh I'm at this point where I'm like
I don't need to figure anything out
because I still have the reason why I've
hated doing these and or had not hated
but had trepidation approaching these
these podcasts every year is that I feel
like I got to have something to show you
know I gotta there's some external that
I'm answering to and I'm just in a place
right now where it's like nope
no I don't I don't I'm totally okay with
what's going on with me
and I'm not saying any of this
I'm
I'm really trying to catch myself any
moment that I start to think how anybody
could take it
and instead just saying
I'm not the main way that I interact
with the world is not like
I don't I I I don't have
my brain
doesn't work in a way where like I
I like
dig into something and then I got
something powerful to say about it
I'm and I think what but what I do have
and realizing who I am and what
how I can love myself and how I can how
I want to be in this world is something
that I'll get to but it's different than
that for me so it's get letting myself
off the hook to say officially I resolve
to to know nothing to have no
um defense
like
a verbal defense for for for my
belief to have some coherent uh world
view where someone would say what a
cogent boy is he you know it's just
uh that's just another level of pressure
and it just invites a lot of
self-judgment
you know that I'm not something that I
feel like I should be should should but
I am I am what I am and uh
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be who I'm gonna
be who I am and I'm gonna see where that
goes
I don't know if any of this is making
any sense what do you hear me saying
um
I hear you saying that you are
discovering
uh or embracing
Who You Are
and that there is a uh all you can do
is be
the best you that you can be
and you're kind of figuring out what
that
what that looks like yeah
I think I can get into some specifics
that I'll like
flesh it out a little bit more
um
I you know it's
having some certain tenets
like
being present
receiving love giving love like
um when I feel like I'm in like
when I feel like I'm in my sweet spot
uh
spiritually or in in any way
physically when I'm when I feel like
vibrant and healthy the thing that I
find myself saying is I got love to give
if you if you want it here it is like
that I mean I just feel like there's
some
uh when when I'm in that zone
it's
it kind of feels magical
and it's and it's in it's beautifully
simple and that's that's what I say I
got I found myself having love to give
not and nothing feels better
there's a lot of things that feel good
but like that feels really good that's
definitely up there
that's definitely up there in terms of
like
like having this secure sense of
being of of being okay of being
uh good
uh that's that's how it comes out that's
how it comes out of my mouth I gotta
love to give maybe I'll tattoo that on
my body in Elvish in Elvis everything's
got to be an Elvis but I got to get a
child to do it too you know
one of my children me and Lily have an
Elvis tattoo in our arm if you don't
know that's what I'm referring to so
every time I get an Elvis tattoo on my
body I gotta get a child somewhere in
the world to also get I got I got to get
one of my Offspring to also get it on
their body just kind of no I don't um
shoes
yeah it's like Tom's shoes or bombas
socks I want to keep it simple man hit
you know what
I
you know what I'll put it this way I I'm
gonna
uh I am just I'm gonna I'm inventing my
own religion okay uh oh this is what I'm
gonna do I'm doing this I'm inventing my
own religion it's just for me uh-oh and
if you don't want to hear it don't
listen because I'm about to tell you
about the religion that I'm inventing
this just for me it's not for you
it's not for anybody else
it can only be for me it can't be for
anybody else because it's just something
that I'm inventing just for me I don't
want you to take any of it unless you I
don't care if you take any of it but
like
yeah this is what I'm doing I'm and it's
real simple
I've written in my journal
I and I don't know what I'm gonna call
it
but
it's it's an animal religion
and it's I am I'm not work and it's my
animals and I'm not worshiping my
animals but I'm taking inspiration from
my animals
to for my spiritual practice I won't
call it a religion spiritual practice
that sounds better so I've got a
channeling my animals channeling that
doesn't sound right either because that
sounds
because when you Channel something
you're like speaking for them
I think I'm I'm allowing my animals to
inspire me so I would like to take you
through my animals okay and what I'm
learning from each of them
okay yeah and then maybe I'll come up
with a name for it for this uh news
spirituality
I gotta start with Jade nope this is
Jasper
Jasper you got to go
he doesn't get a start no
nope
Jay
I don't think this is the type of thing
I'm gonna travel to youth groups and
teach
it's just for me don't speak so fast
it could be kind of awesome it could be
good money in it
is this part of it this is part of it
Jade
is teaching me
to just
sit in it
whatever it is just sit in it
she knows how to curl up in the warm
spots
and just be there
thank you
she knows how to receive love
and she knows how
to give love
and it's simple like she'll just curl up
receiving love and giving love happen at
the same time with her
I've been I don't know what it is this
year but I've like
I've just been obsessed with my doggies
it's just ridiculous
it's ridiculous
I love my dog so much it's just crazy
I think getting Jade's face on my arm it
was like a self-fulfilling prophecy
I think it like it solidified something
in me that was like I don't know what it
means about me that I have my living
dog's face on my
forearm
but I know that it is is a
representation of me
like I know that it means me
but I can't tell you exactly what it
means
thank you Jay I'm not worshiping you I'm
just being inspired by you yeah there's
a difference there's a difference
I want to
you know I'm we're blessed by being
loved by a lot of people
like as fans you know
but also in in our personal lives like
and there's a difference between like
just having that and and receiving it
like there's just a magic to like saying
I'm gonna sit I'm gonna receive
love like somebody like Lando comes up
to me and
he just wants to give me a hug
and there's like oh I'm gonna hug you
back because I love you but then there's
a type of hug where
there's like
something's being transferred
yeah
um
does this sound weird I don't know it's
just like well yes you can be in a
moment where it's like okay I'm gonna
and for me it still is a lot of
breathing like if you if you hug me
there might be like a deep breath like a
like a last breath oh did he just die
like that's when you that's when it gets
real good
um and I think that when I when I sit
with Jade that's that's that's what I'm
reminded of that like it can it can be
simple
it can be it can be boiled down to
something that simple as like curling up
in the now and being loved
which directly
fuels it's like a cycle then you're
you're given love you get in love
that's Jade
go away Jake come here Jasper
me and Jasper been taking some good
walks
sometimes Jade's invited but usually
she's not
do you profess that you are a sinner it
does feel it feels like I'm going to
baptize it it does feel a little
religious
ceremonial Jasper
uh
Jasper inspires me he's not as
comfortable as Jade right now you get
comfortable
he likes to be held a different way his
legs are too long he likes to be held
like this
um
Jasper
has this
enthusiasm for
beautiful stuff
all that bird imma chase that bird
because it's beautiful not because I
want to eat it or there's some sort of
instinct but the root but no I don't
know why he does it but I get so much
joy from uh
because I found this place where I can
safely let him off the leash that's like
completely contained
and we go to this spot and it's just he
just has this enthusiasm
that is contagious and he is curiosity
that is
um
inspiring
so
he doesn't there's a lot that he doesn't
know he doesn't he doesn't have a lot
figured out
and
I don't he doesn't care at all he
doesn't care because when he goes for a
walk he's just like
enthusiastically soaking it in like a
sponge
and there's always somewhere you can
look to be
to find something worth taking in
and he's he's really good at that
he also likes to like pee on stuff a lot
that's not part of it
and you know it's just
um
being with my dogs is so fun for me and
it's so life-giving and so I'm just I'm
constructing a spiritual practice around
it that grounds me
is really all I'm saying
you know it's um
and a lot of it is just you know it's
that the times when I'm alone
there's a lot of times when I'm just
sitting or doing something and it's just
I got I got both the dogs so I got both
of those
reminders
good boy
I also have a cat hmm
Saka Saka is
um he's really he's he's coming he's
coming around like we're trying to get
Jade to
we're we're not allowing Jade to run
Saka off as much and he's coming around
more
and communing with with uh with us
and receiving more scritches
um but the thing and the thing about
soccer is I just he's so fun to watch
like
the best thing about a cat that I've
found so far is that it's just they're
fun to spectate
um so there's not it's not an up close
and personal connection but the things
that I'm learning
from Saka
is the the power of being quiet you know
one of the things that I'm working on is
I'm still working on is like
uh listening
not interrupting in conversations
uh
and so Saka is is kind of a he kind of
grounds me in that like he's really good
at being quiet
I mean he's sneaky
uh but
I think that ties into like um the more
powerful thing that I'm getting from
Saka is
the fact that he's
he seems so centered
like not maybe he's self-centered maybe
you could say that now that's not really
what I'm focusing on but just being
centered I think for me
not
completely
defining myself based on external
relationships
[Music]
um
this definitely comes home to roost for
me in terms of that judgment thing where
it's
foreign
you know there was my entire upbringing
there was this sense of I'm being
watched and I need that external
approval
you know from God every night I need to
I gotta find the things to confess you
know I've got to I've got to clear the
air you know
uh I've got a spiritually breathe out in
my sins and receive
forgiveness and love from the Holy
Spirit
that I mean I that
that never worked for me back then
so now it's it's a cat religion I'm
trying to
just
accept it
I
it's been really hard to convince myself
that I'm a good person
it's been really really hard to do that
and it's
uh
you know I discovered that therapy for
me like the way that I approach therapy
was I just wanted my therapist to tell
me that I was okay that I was good I
wanted my therapists to do things that a
therapist is not supposed to do and and
thankfully
he hasn't died
um and I looked I looked to you know I
sometimes I put Christy in a tough
position and
um you know it's one thing to ask where
it's
I need I need you to determine if I am
you know my Center is like outside of
myself I need I need to be validated
you know it's it's one thing to have
like a deep conversation with you and
ask you for advice and like get your
input but like
um
and that's good but it's another thing
to uh
it's
get you to certify
something about me that I think I had I
that I've
I've needed to find for myself
and I think I think I'm I think I'm
doing a
I think I'm doing a better job of that
of saying okay I
know
I'm getting to know myself
in a in a new way in kind of a
maybe a deeper level I don't know in us
um
and finding some finding some security
in that
you know that it's
it's not about
like I said at the beginning of this
like even to uh our audience like prove
like saying something that makes them
feel a certain way about me coming to
some conclusion about me so that then
when I see it in the comments it
validates what I hope is true about me
you know that's not
um that's not what Saka does
you know so I I've just found that it's
just it's this beautiful creature in my
house that can can bring me back to that
who Who Am I who do I want to be
what are what are my reasons for myself
they don't have to be shared with
anybody necessarily I even have a
healthy separation from you know some
people might talk about there's like
codependents at play here I don't know
the terms
you know
but it's like having a healthy
separation where where I and and Christy
begins you know where I end and you
begin in in our relationship
um
and it's
I am seeing that that's there's like a
it's very freeing to to do that like
when I find myself that's like centered
where my I'm not giving somebody else
power to dictate what I think about
myself
it it gives me a freedom to be present
and to
not only love
people but also
enjoy
um
enjoy other people's moments
uh and especially like in in for us like
when so so much of everything has both
of our names on it like I've found that
those the moments when I feel the most
centered I and I I feel this level of
security that like
um
I in like I enjoy where I've stopped and
you've started and kind of spectating
that in your work
um
and that's that just feels really good
you know
um so
the cat brings me back to that
I think I need more animals well that
was I was going to ask you because
that's all I got because in terms of
animals because it feels like the I
think that may be all I need the
inevitable outcome of practicing this
religion is that you're gonna become one
of those houses that's like a zoo and
they are yes and this one does this for
me and this one does this for me
well just the other day I heard Christy
talking to you
about some litter of puppies that
somebody had that was like well no it
was a bunch of puppies they were walking
around with in the neighborhood or
something I just can't I I don't no
we're in a holding pad I can't it's not
gonna happen because I can't
well can you learn things from other
animals yeah I can I bet y'all can learn
some stuff from your animals well no
well not just other people's animals but
you could also go to the zoo
it's like who is this man that has an
annual pass to the zoo that just comes
and sits every day in front of the
ostriches right what are you doing sir
I'm learning from the ostriches
is weird but it's for totally other
reasons you could just observe other
animals and and you well you know what
actually I think I've just developed a
theory
um you know every once in a while so
probably probably every day if not every
week or month there is someone in the
world who enters an enclosure at a zoo
and I believe those people are
independently practicing your religion
now it makes it why did this guy go into
the the lion exhibit because he's
practicing linkism
he's like I can only get learn so much
from this lion by sitting here on this
bench next to this Grandma who doesn't
want to be here I must stroke his name
and the next thing you know you're in
the moat and then harambe is bringing
you up and embracing you
uh that could be your future
you're gonna have to leash me at the zoo
red I'm ready to go to the zoo again you
could also be a natural nature
photographer
or bird watcher
what can you learn from Birds maybe
that's what bird watchers have been
doing all this time
Maybe
yeah I could do that I could be that to
bring it back into the human realm I was
listening to brene Brown
interview at the end of last year uh uh
Father Richard Rohr yeah
um he's a father of what what is it is
he a I think he's a Jesuit I mean he's a
Catholic okay
and what is brene brown she's a she's a
Texan
I think she is a
I don't know I think maybe deconstructed
Evangelical
um I'm not sure she she's got a lot of
good stuff to say
uh I'm not a you know so I I I just
found well here's the one thing I wanted
to highlight from there's the part two
of their December 2022 conversation
um she she asked him like what's the
good word I don't even know what that
question means
apparently he did he was like I'm just
spitballing here like off the top of his
head and he said
uh I I'll I took a screenshot of the
transcript
so he replied he said
the good word is whatever I'm just
stabbing at this but whatever Point she
toured what we call the three
transcendentals in Scholastic philosophy
the good the true and the Beautiful
if it points you toward those it's a
good word
and I'm going to read the second half of
his quote in a second but I just want to
camp out there for a second like
the good the true and the Beautiful if
it points you towards those it's a good
word I just
it's okay I like that's that's simple
that's like she's just kind of like you
know it's been that's been cooking that
should boil down that's one of those
sauces that's just that's a good tasting
sauce you know that's like you know
what's that pot of stuff you get the the
pork contentsu you know it's like it's
been boiling for a long time it was just
a simmering and it's just
okay easy simple maybe not easy simple I
like that
the good it's kind of like The Bold and
the Beautiful You know the soap opera
sort of but there's only two of those
yeah
the good the true and the Beautiful and
if you know when I say okay so the true
in that like if I say well I was off to
not know anything well okay
I'll I'll I'm willing to fudge a little
bit like I'm I'm willing to focus on
things that I know are true you know
I like how you talk about
true stuff I like how you talk about
stuff that you've convinced that that
you like okay this is true like these
are things
I've I've I've nailed this stake into
the into the solid into the solid place
and I'm gonna hold on to it this is so
I'm convinced of this
like and there's
I like it when you do that
I don't I don't do that much of that but
I acknowledge that okay
if there's some if it's true let's go
let's go with it if it's good let's go
with this it's beautiful let's go with
it
um
but then he he said an interesting thing
like right on the heels of it off the
top of his head and again brene Brown
um she's an author she's a speaker she's
not funny
she is well she's funny but she can't
well I wouldn't call her a comedian
right she's not a comedian she has a
great sense of humor she's got a good
sense of humor
but I don't think that accounts for why
he would just go here
maybe it was just for me hmm
I don't think that's the healthy way to
think about it yeah I don't think it was
but I I do find it interesting this is
the next thing he says after he says the
good the true and the Beautiful it
points you towards those things it's a
good word that's why I often think some
comedy
some
is just teaching you how to be cynical
it doesn't point you towards the good
the true and the Beautiful
and I enjoy Seinfeld as much as the next
person but just when you go on for half
an hour with cynical remarks about
everything you destroy the contemplative
mind
you can't just see the good that's there
the truth is there
and brene said the beauty now we let
Seinfeld's our favorite show of all time
right
and we're comedians
so I'm likely
some might say
but I felt like
it was just it was weird that he used
comedy as like the as the one place that
he could have gone of all the places he
could have gone to illustrate the good
the true and the Beautiful he used
comedy and he used Seinfeld he throws
Seinfeld under the bus even though he's
a fan and
it it
along with a number of other things that
have happened to me and to us and
conversations we've had over the past
few months I'm picking up where your
conversation left off last time okay
foreign
gaining a deeper appreciation for what
how our creative expression is a
spiritual exercise
and it has
and how it touches people
I would never have said that what we do
and I'll put a lot of this just in terms
of me but like and you know I think so
much of it applies to YouTube but this
is my podcast
episode what episode yeah this episode
um
I never would have said that what I do
and the content that we make
is medicine
that it's
it that it has healing properties but
we've been told that for for years
I was in the hospital and I discovered
you guys
I I made it through a tough time because
of you guys I
you are my Comfort viewing
five days out of the week you're my safe
escape from the what life is throwing at
me right now
um
or the thing that the aspect of my life
that I will never be able to get away
from
there's like a I actually do a little
bit when I'm hanging out with you guys
and I feel like we've known that to 80
but I feel like in the last I don't know
in the last
few weeks or so
I feel like we've gained just this
deeper appreciation that kind of maybe
take it to 95 of like
wow uh we've just
uh what we thought was a byproduct of
what we do might just have been the
product the whole time
and
it's Felt So Good
to
realize that
to realize that you know if I've had a
hard time just being convinced that
uh that I'm a good person
well it turns out that
uh it's been happening that that has
it's been true all along
I I think it's been true more and more
because I do think I'm on a positive
Journey you know
um
so I'm just I'm just extremely moved by
the fact that
what
what what we're doing
it doesn't have the appearance of
um
you know this groundbreaking
earth-shattering
um
book or speech or
but it's
is I don't know it's it's just as
it's been just as special to people
like
I'm receiving I'm receiving that love
and I'm giving that I I I feel like I
have more confidence to just
just myself be as weird as me you know
that all of that stuff is just I think
it's coming together on a deeper level
for me that's like
um
I
uh the gifts that I have are gifts to
give and it's and uh I understand that
we've been I've been doing that we've
been doing that and but I understand it
more now so like what does that mean
what does that mean
for
for what's next
I I feel very uh
confirmed that I'm in the right place
you know that I'm that I'm doing the
right
work from me
and
then it
yeah yeah and then it comes out
uh it feels so good that like it then
from that position it comes out
it it overflows in a way that like
helps people
reaches people
um
well I think that uh we have been
slow to
realize that
and embrace that the the fact that
our work is medicine
because
that is not how
entertainment in general is thought
that's never how I thought about
entertainment right yeah
I mean not only did we create a business
around entertainment which like I talked
about last week sometimes
business interests compromise the
creative voice
and the creative act but also
much of uh a lot of people's inclination
for creating something is to bring the
attention to themselves that's what we
always talk about is like we just wanted
to be the center of attention oh yeah
you know and I think that is a big part
of it that's a big part of it for a lot
of people in comedy not just being the
center of attention but also deflection
and you know and putting on a shell and
putting on a personality to not have to
encounter pain
or or whatever
um and so because and then the reward
system the incentive is money and
attention
validation that you're talking about
whether it be going to a list of you
know a collection of comments and trying
to
Garner your self-worth from what people
say about you there's a lot of
incentives there that are that distract
from being able to just realize even
though yes many people have told us
this thing that you created
it wasn't about you create something so
I can admire you and your talent
or give you an award but it literally is
the creative act being experienced by
someone else
is in some ineffable way is healing
and I thought we I think we both thought
right for
like we would look at well you know if I
watch stuff on HBO I watch these
scripted series or I watch these like
these these well-crafted movies and they
like they move you and they
they can change your mind and they can
change your heart and they can make you
cry and they can
connect with your soul again like plug
into you like that's art
what we do is dumb
what we do is silly
what we do is is funny and it's and it's
it's
not it's not heavy so it's not
meaningful it's not
and you know we sit there and we we
wanted we've been wanting to do that so
bad we want what we want to tell stories
and we want you know because that's how
you capture people and their their
imagination and
um move people and we want to we gotta
do that so let's let's go after that
and then it's like meanwhile all along
we've been we'd be we were already doing
it we're already doing it I'm not saying
with that we can't script something that
we can't go after those things because
it still would be very fun but like
if we ever did something like that again
it would be it wouldn't be for lack of
already yeah doing it like I just have
I don't know you know we've been very
we've been as close as you can be to
what we're doing so it's like it's
really hard to see from the inside out
um so I think when I look at our work
I've just been able to see it
um
with fresh eyes and just
it's just by
it was just kind of coincidental
that it happened it wasn't it wasn't
planned I just feel very fortunate that
it it happened and I don't and I and
it's and I don't believe that it's just
well it is a reflection of just who we
are but
uh it's more than that
like is there something else going on
here is there something else at work
it's like we didn't do it on purpose so
maybe so
that would be
I'm open to that
you know
I kind of I kind of lean towards that
being the conclusion that there's
something else at work here I don't you
know I
I hope it doesn't sound like I'm kind of
like building us up as like some
something awesome again I think this is
just this is a conversation that will
that is really for me and you if people
you know anybody listening we shouldn't
release this well they can they can do
whatever they want with it but like I
would
so I'm here I'm I'm hoping that people
don't think of it as like oh my God
these guys are they think they're
saviors hell no
I just feel very when you find
that you're
me being me and not being what I'm not
being what I am
uh
has
is is this is The Sweet Spot only I can
be me and uh I can let go of the things
that
I'm not going
that aren't me
you know
um
some of which are you
by the way so it's it's a great
partnership
uh uh it I'm just saying it feels good
it just feels it feels really good to be
of service and to be and to find more
Security in myself and
um
I don't know
I I don't feel like I'm saying anything
they're very cogent but I I but I feel
very that's what I want I wanted to
comment on that because you said that at
the top
I don't know how you said it you said
something about that you're not good at
um
the thinking something and then
communicating it but I think that this
podcast is evidence of the contrary well
I now that you're in and I couldn't
write it down not that you're interested
in here and I wouldn't give a speech
that's not why you did that
um
but I think that this is going to be
very helpful for a lot of people and
again that's not the point of it but I'm
just saying we do release this into the
world and I do think people will benefit
from it I would love that I also think
I've been I mean I was I didn't want to
interrupt you of course I'm thinking
things the whole time I think I've gone
through everything I wanted to say
um oh I had one story
but yeah
it's related to that and then you can
kind of put that on it but like
um this story is related to
being
well I'll just tell the story
back when we were
on staff of Campus Crusade and every
year
we and we would emcee the uh
the Christmas Time conference the
Christmas the Christmas conference we
called it Christmas time but then we
changed the name of the conference to we
got a new director of the conference to
come in and he called he was like we're
going to change the name of it
to encounter
we're going to like rebuild this
conference from the ground up and
um so we got together we were we as the
MCs
and um our good friend Mark as like a
logistics director of the main stage
show and then Chris as the Director of
the entire conference and then this
other guy
who um
shall remain nameless
he was the music leader like the praise
and worship music guy this year and you
know we had probably done it six years
by this point
and I think it was his first or second
year as the music guy and Mark as a
logistics guy it was like his 10th or
12th year and Chris it was like his
first year but he's like a big Ideas guy
and we sat in a room and we said
everything that we've done every year
and we said is the template for the main
show program
we're gonna throw that out and we're
just going to rebuild it and so like
everything was being reinvented
um
and we're they were we were designing
everything for like this immersive
experience
to encounter God
and at one point the music guy turns to
us and he says something to the effect
of why is what you do important here
do you remember that oh yeah
and I remember and of course
we were making out you would make
announcements we would make funny videos
we would write funny songs we would have
funny crowd interaction we did comedy if
you removed it from the conference there
was nothing Christian or religious about
it
and as we're rebuilding this thing from
the ground up where people want to
encounter God
you know he was just
I don't I don't know if he was
doing it for a fact I don't know if he
was doing it to make a point I don't
know if he was doing it for criticism I
don't know why he was doing it but I
felt like
when he asked the question I was caught
it was like oh no you got me you know I
felt completely
like rejected and just because because
to me it was like oh you're you're
insinuating that we don't need to be a
part of this that we are not a
contributing factor to the main goal
here what is it you do here and just for
a little more color on that
I believe a big motivation uh whether it
was conscious or not for him to bring
this up and see things in this way was
the pattern that was happening over the
course of the 90s and as we got into the
late 90s
in the early 2000s what was happening
with passion
namely right so passion was a giant I
don't know if they still do it they
probably do passion was a big annual
conference for a bunch of Christian
college students came together and you
know characterized by like great praise
and worship music and speakers and stuff
and it was becoming the thing that we
were losing students to
and passion was very serious it was very
spiritual it was very deep and it did
not have this
um I'm not saying that somebody not
might not say something funny but it
wasn't centered around these two
comedians who are doing these ridiculous
videos and getting people up on stage
and cutting their hair over the course
of a week or making them drink a gallon
of milk every day and try to gain 12
pounds in one week we did a bunch of
weird
um and there was a seriousness to that
movement that was happening that we were
beginning to sense
and I remember thinking well maybe this
whole like really light-hearted comedy
thing was just something that happened
in the early 90s in Christian circles
and like right it's phasing out and
we've got to adjust with it so I think
that
he had been to that conference and seen
the way they do things and then you
compare it to the way that we're up
there being fools and it felt different
and maybe even a reverent
and I didn't know what to say I couldn't
I couldn't put a defense into words
and
I don't remember what you said but I
have to believe that you
you definitely you probably had a much
more
um
whether you said it or not like you had
a much more offensive reaction than than
I had a more defensive reaction
um I don't I don't know that you were as
phased by it as I was but like
you know it's just I didn't see
I didn't I couldn't articulate
what I could feel
and that was
this is this is where
one important part of this we're
bringing something
we have a gift to give here and it isn't
it is important I mean
you know there were other people at the
at the table so making decisions more
than the people I I mentioned I think
and so we ended up having some nights
that were like completely serious but
yeah we still had our fun we weren't
kicked to the curb it was just one
question from one person and then it you
know but I I don't know it just the echo
of that memory came back to me now as
like
I'm still
owning
and processing the fact that
what you know we're in this
we're in this um
we're exercising we're exercising
something that's like a spiritual
practice in in our level uh in you know
you know like
in the way that we do things I think
it's it's
I don't know exactly what I'm saying but
maybe I'm saying first of all it can all
be spiritual
you know I you know you hear about
um the monks talking about like you know
yeah uh
maybe it's the the Buddhist saying of
like
the Kerry water saying I can't remember
what it is right now
you want about do this carry water do
that it's a Buddhist saying or like
whatever you know everything can be a
spiritual practice if it's you know you
know like nurturing your plants like uh
Christie does or like
dusting your shelves you know it can all
be a spiritual practice you know that's
not part of my religion
uh I just feel
um
it feels good to be able to say these
things uh and come to these realizations
about the opportunity we have but then
it at the same time I don't feel an
ounce of pressure
I don't feel an ounce of external
pressure or just like okay now you got
to live up to this you're talking
I do not I do not feel that I'm not I'm
not gonna let myself feel that because
it's like that takes me out of this
sweet spot of like
um nobody's watching
I know that ain't true but like I I need
to
you know I need to dance like nobody's
watching
you know I need to feel the rain on my
skin
and if I do that if I'm true to
to to that
um
I feel like good things will happen
I agree
yeah before thanks Jenna before
Enlightenment chop wood carry water
after Enlightenment chop wood carry
water this is Zen Buddhist phrase
emphasizing the need for committing to
and thriving during the process of any
Pursuit
child would carry water
um
I think this is a good religion link
um spiritual practice
I think that
um
you know
I think that one of the things that
you're kind of uh that you're you're
hinting at which is so important
there's something
um
you know observing your animals
and learning from your animals
I mean first of all this is something
that you know this is an it is an
age-old practice sorry I mean you didn't
invent it
um
but uh
that's a good thing
and I think that one of the reasons that
it's so powerful is
because you are an animal
yeah
um
and I think that there is you know I
again you're right that
and I get in my and I do I mean not you
aren't saying this I have a tendency to
I hear what you're saying and then the
way that I work the the me being myself
is hearing the things that you're saying
and synthesizing it and creating a way
of expressing it
and thinking about it that's how I sort
of latch onto things and carry them
forward for me personally
but
this is again it's ironic because the
thing that I'm the observation that I'm
making is that
um when we are more like our animals in
the ways that you just described
we get out of our way
yeah in the way that we tend to get in
the way of ourselves and having true
experiences uh that you can't I mean I'm
sure there is some sort of Truth
some combination of whether it's all
natural phenomenon or phenomena or
whether there's some sort of
Supernatural thing that's happening I
think the point that I hear you making
is that
parsing that and understanding that is
actually has nothing to do with
experiencing it fully yeah
and a lot of times trying to parse it
and Define it analyze it systematize it
takes all the beauty and even some of
the truth out of it
and the goodness
and this is really real for us in our
background
because we come from
you know a religious tradition
that was was a system of system
systemizing God
yeah and then within the system of of of
this organized organized religion we
were in one of the very specific strands
that was the most organized
of the organized religions
when you when you start talking about
uh reformed thinking I mean we had a
book that we kept next to our Bible
called Systematic Theology yeah
and and that used to make me feel good
from Wayne grudum right yeah and I think
that the idea was that this guy by
Consulting a bunch of other really smart
guys over the over the course of history
was going to help you understand these
things that God was communicating in the
Bible and help you systematize it help
you organize it help you cross-reference
it help and
this is attractive to certain Minds this
is attractive to my mind
but
in a lot of ways whatever truth and
beauty and goodness there is and
whatever is happening with God
um
I tend to think that this is not adding
systematizing it to that degree is not
adding anything and most likely it's
taking a lot away
and I haven't
like I felt good about having it and
reading it but like
I've never been able to like then
say it
or like
order to to my brain is to have hasn't
worked that way where it's like I would
retain it in a way that like
I'm like actually
um
utilizing it specifically
I I feel like
this is cut this is kind of
I'm at a point now where it's like yeah
it's not it's not me to be able to
figure out these things or like to be
able to like turn around and tell
somebody about it or to like write an
essay about it that would move somebody
or change somebody's mind for me I'm
realizing that that's just not in my
repertoire
and
um
and I but I shouldn't feel
I shouldn't feel bad about that I
shouldn't feel guilty about it you know
it's probably
because you have that ability it might
there might be a different uh
struggle there for you for me it's just
kind of like uh the freedom of letting
myself off the hook that like I don't
have to know and I don't have to feel
bad for not knowing and I don't have to
feel bad when somebody asks me that like
I can't even begin to put something
together uh that's like a response to
your to that if it was a question or
whatever you know so
um well and and I just think it puts me
so
that that's another type of centering
for me that's like oh who I am and what
I'm able how I interact with
everything
I can be I can be centered and like okay
that's just
I'm not going to go down that path
because uh I'm gonna come back with
nothing anyway except guilt that I don't
have anything
well and back to the animals
um
animals other than Lassie
uh when they experience something
they just come to you and they
they have a way of being
that that they cannot explain
right
um and I think what I'm saying in it and
this is for and I'm saying this to
myself because
whatever the truth is that exists
because I do believe there is a truth
that exists there is something that's
happening right there is something that
you are experiencing
there's something that I'm experiencing
there's something that we are
experiencing there is some there is
truth to the fabric of the universe
that we may or may
not ever know
but the very language that we are
communicating in right now is already at
least one layer removed from the
experience and is already making it a
bastardized version of it if there's
some spiritual thing that you can
experience
the moment that you put it into words
you have changed it
yeah that feels right and so a dog
doesn't do that no
a dog is just experiencing in fact a dog
doesn't even have the ability as far as
I know
to have a memory of the experience
they're so in the moment that they're
just kind of in they're having the
experience from and I think that that's
right that's what I hear you getting at
and so I think it's just a recognition
that a lot of these things like our our
need to understand and
um
you know build a system to remember
things to be able to explain ourselves
to be able to defend ourselves which is
a big thing for me is wanting to appear
credible and being able to be uh
understood
these are all things that are
potentially hindrances to
actually experiencing the spiritual yeah
and it's tough for you because you're
good at it it's tough for me because I
wasn't I've never been good at it so we
each have our own way to get to it seems
like we want to get to the same place
but we have different things that we've
needed to get over in order to get there
um when that's the whole idea of
there being more of a Stillness and a
passivity and a reception of whatever it
is that's happening
because even in these conversations that
we're having about
whatever is going on with us creatively
in making the connection between
the
the creative act and the spiritual
practice
um
not having to define it
planet
execute it
before it
sort of reveals itself and that's a
faith practice
okay you know
yeah
yeah and that's that's very difficult
for me because the moment that I start
realizing something I begin building
something
you know I begin writing something I
begin
developing something
and I in one sense I can't that's who I
am and I can't stop that if something
comes to me I'm gonna
try to understand it and try to put it
in some form and kind of throw it back
um
but there are certain times we're just
sitting and just being like okay I'm
sort of observing what what is going on
and we've got some good friends who are
helping us
kind of process this stuff too in a way
that has been comforting for me they're
not gurus
um they're just good they're just good
friends who have creative minds as well
and are you know on their own Journey
but I think that being able to when when
we see something that we get excited
about and it's like what is it that's
happening and what what is it that we're
experiencing and how does this translate
into
the things that we bring into the world
whether that's using our comedy for
healing or just creating for
creativity's sake whatever that might be
um being okay
with not being okay with being a dog
you know
yeah and just being like well
what would what would Jasper do what
would well Sean would in the house
so that's what I've if I was to follow
your religion I would be and
pissing in my house
without regard
uh to anything
I would also be
biting people regularly and I would be
barking at everything that wasn't
exactly normal
so I don't want to learn everything from
dogs nope nope
uh but I but yeah I think that I'm just
very I'm very hopeful and excited I mean
I feel I feel you know I think that
we articulate it in different ways and
you were coming to different
realizations because we are different
people
but there is a synchronicity to what's
happening that is exciting to me yeah
yeah
I mean I just
you know people people think different
things about the word happy
and but
um
right now I'm I think I'm the happiest
I've ever been in my entire life
hmm
and it's okay if that
I don't expect this level of Happiness
to continue forever but like uh
I'm not going to forget it and I'm very
grateful for it but I think I am the
happiest I've ever been in my entire
life
isn't that crazy I'm glad I'm here for
it isn't that crazy
you're not wild
you're not special
isn't that something
or nothing
well
there it is there it is
let's bring it to a close
ah ah can I make a recommendation let me
know hashtag your biscuits
uh what you think about this or I mean
you can tell us what you think uh or how
you're processing this by leaving us a
voicemail one eight eight eight
earpod one or you can just talk to
somebody that you love
foreign
about this or whatever
man I got a lot of good stuff that I
want to recommend what am I gonna do
all right I'm gonna do this one
the album is called Mother Earth's
plantasia
[Laughter]
seemed like the one
because if Chrissy was given this
podcast she she might be she she might
be talking about her plant religion
and I found this for her this album was
released in 1976 by Mort Garson
Mort Garson who was like an a digital
music pioneer
but he made this album
um
plants
yeah
but you'll like it too
it's 30 minutes 51 seconds
plantasia
you're welcome
hey guys I uh just listened to your
Rhett's deconstruction and uh just
wanted to say thank you I grew up in the
South watching you guys and
out of the Bible Belt in a pastor's home
and I've been able to explore my
spirituality a little bit and I don't
know what the hell is going on uh but
it's really comforting to hear your
stories and Brett I appreciate you
saying what she said it's helped me put
towards some of the things that I've
been feeling so I appreciate you guys
being vulnerable love you guys
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]